quand est ce que je serai remboursé
puis je faire une cure thermale cette
année je pars en vacances à l'étranger
est ce que ma mutuelle voyage avec moi
vous avez toujours plein de question
pour nous et c'est tant mieux car nous
sommes là pour y répondre
téléphonez nous ou demander à être
rappelé tout est clair et précis sur
notre site
une mutuelle qui vit avec vous votre
quotidien
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
revenez clic et on en parle
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
check-up votre émission santé et
bien-être
au programme de ce numéro suite aux
attentats du 13 novembre vous avez été
nombreux à vous mobiliser pour donner
votre sang retour sur cette mobilisation
yvelinoise à l'hôpital du chesnay
quel rapport les français entretiennent
avec leur pharmacie c'est le sujet de la
pièce tranches de vie sur ordonnance qui
se jouait à elancourt une pièce
interactive qui pousse à s'interroger
sur notre consommation de médicaments et
pour terminer comment détecter les
polluants intérieurs et comment
l'environnement impacte notre santé la
mutualité française répond à ces
questions en organisant des ateliers
nesting mais pour commencer le 1er
décembre était la journée mondiale de
lutte contre le sida chaque année des
milliers de français se mobilisent pour
participer au sidaction
chacun à leur manière comme au lycée
louis blériot à trappes où l'artiste
jitrois a été invité pour réaliser une
fresque géante à la craie dans la cour
de l'établissement avec les élèves
on écoute justin langlade la professeur
chargé du projet avec l'artiste
on a contacté l'artiste jitrois qui
travaille à la craie dans l'espace
public et on fait ces arabes et nous ont
fait penser à des rubans et donc le
ruban du sidaction
puis en plus le travail de j 3 ça
raconte l'espace de l'art dans l'espace
public ce qu'on a travaillé aussi avec
les élèves donc il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se rejoignent et puis voilà pour une
journée de prévention comme ça et puis
les sensibiliser au sida y est c'est
risqué
est ce que ça implique les profs n'ont
pas d'objectifs vraiment c'est tout
simplement de tourner autour du ruban
essayer de jouer avec ça des jouets vous
avez simplement montrer mes motifs mais
c'était soit vous travaillez avec les
motifs de jordan ou enfin de j 3 ou soit
vous faites autre chose un peu un côté
s'exprimer d'abord à la craie simplement
je pense que c'était sa de base pour le
sidaction
ils sont curieux je m'attendais pas à ça
c'est vrai j'avais un peu d'appréhension
effectivement est en fait au final pas
du tout sur ie participatif à fond
après les tragiques l'attentât du
vendredi 13 novembre les français
étaient nombreux à se mobiliser et à
s'être déplacés pour donner spontanément
leur centre conséquence le fs
établissements français du don du sang à
enregistrer des dons record florane
parfait s'est rendu à l'hôpital du
chesnay roi portage plus de 200 dons au
chesnay ce samedi c'est presque deux
fois plus que d'habitude pour ce jour de
la semaine
par solidarité pour les victimes des
attentats tragiques de vendredi à paris
ils sont nombreux à s'être déplacés pour
certains ce n'est pas dans leurs
habitudes
je l'avais jamais donné avant parce que
tout simplement depuis je suis majeur
fin j'avais pas mal de piercings
tatouages et avec ce qu'ils demandent
c'est trop de restrictions nous du coup
c'était pas possible de le faire
puis là ça c'est vraiment les événements
de ce week-end la première fois c'était
charlie hebdo pareil moi j'ai mon école
qui est juste la place de république
donc carrément on était venu dans notre
école pour participer au don du sang
donc c'était la première fois et là du
coup c'était la deuxième fois sur toute
la france neuf mille dons ont été
enregistrés
un record pour le f s plus habitué à
recenser deux mille donateurs habituels
les stocks ont permis en ile-de-france
de gérer les besoins actuels pour les
blessés des attentats
l'établissement a reçu suffisamment de
dons mais appelle ses donateurs à rester
mobilisés nous allons avoir besoin de
ces mêmes donneurs spontanée dans les
trois semaines qui viennent voir quatre
semaines tous les blessés de vendredi
vont subir des interventions
chirurgicales
là pour le coup régler et non pas
d'urgence c'est ce qui s'est passé
vendredi dans les hôpitaux c'est la
chirurgie de guerre donc on a fait à
l'urgence maintenant il ya toute la
chirurgie réparatrice et abdominal et
thoracique est leur taupe et dick et
l'abominable thoracique
ça consomme du sens même avec le
meilleur technique les donneurs
spontanée de samedi ne pourront être
prélevés avant le 15 janvier l'opérateur
de transfusion français espère que cet
élan de solidarité sera durable et
compte aussi sur ses habitués les
attentats
c'était un prétexte pour venir
encore une fois mais on donne tous les
trois mois environ et
je pense que c'était important c'est
surtout important pour les premiers
donneurs qui font leur carte et qui
après reviennent aussi régulièrement
quand nous ont bien mais on est trop peu
à venir il faut attendre huit semaines
entre chaque prélèvement de sang c'est
pourquoi le ffs appelle plutôt les
donneurs à venir pendant les vacances de
noël une période creuse habituellement
c'est une pièce qui tourne depuis
maintenant 15 ans tranche de vie sur
ordonnance interprété par la compagnie
entrée de jeu est une comédie qui se
penche sur l' usage des médicaments et
sur le rapport des français avec leur
pharmacie jouer à elancourt le 19
novembre
cette pièce assez particulière puisque
participative intègre le spectateur en
l'invitant à monter sur scène on regarde
un reportage sur des images de patrick
jacques de dixmude
tu sais l'armoire à pharmacie c'est
comme d'aller voir avec une consommation
de 48 boîtes de médicaments par an les
français font partie des plus gros
consommateurs d'europe en la matière
tranches de vie sur ordonnance c'est le
nom de cette pièce qui remet en question
notre relation entretenue avec notre
pharmacie une comédie qui casse
certaines idées reçues et du progrès à
faire par rapport à nos comportements
puis d'être responsable il faudrait
éviter ce réflexe de surconsommer et
d'aller comme on a la chance d'avoir un
système de sécurité sociale qui
fonctionne encore pas mal les gens
achètent des médicaments parce qu'ils
disent les choix de rembourser dans sa
surconsommation automédication
médicaments génériques
autant de thèmes abordés lors de cette
pièce assez particulière puisque le
public directement mises à contribution
et même invité à monter sur scène
pouvoir
en fin de compte ce n'est que le reflet
de votre vie un peu boboland médicaments
stocker surconsommation auto medica mars
c'est cesser le quotidien le fait d'en
parler c'est bien et puis d'avoir fait
rigoler les gens si cela peut faire
transporter le message c'est barbant un
régime mais il faut savoir le faire mais
échoue peu en fin de compte de diminuer
les doses plutôt que de tout supprimer
c'est une bonne solution
je pense que tu peux ludique je pense
aussi qu'ils retiennent mieux dans le
fait où ils ont participé eux mêmes
c'est pas quelque chose de didactique
c'est pas quelqu'un qui leur a dit on
fait comme si on fait comme ça c'est moi
je suis d'aller sur scène et j'ai fait à
l'est tel choc est destiné aux seniors
tranches de vie sur ordonnance ou pièce
interactive qui apporte des conseils en
poussant le public à s'interroger lui
même sur sa propre consommation
une manière de placer le spectateur en
acteur et sujet principal de la pièce
avec un seul objectif favoriser un bon
usage des médicaments
et pour terminer ce magazine nous nous
sommes rendus aux ateliers nesting à la
verrière ces séances organisée par la
mutualité française d'ile-de-france vous
informe sur les différents polluants de
l'habitat comment l'environnement
impacte notre santé et celle des
nouveaux nés c'est notre journaliste
fanny bon million qui est allé chercher
sa réponse les ateliers nesting apparu
en 2009 en france se développe de plus
en plus mais en quoi consiste-t-il
exactement afin de protéger la santé
d'un nouveau né on lui créer un
environnement intérieur sain et pour
découvrir ces techniques la maison de
quartier de la verrière a organisé un
atelier en partenariat avec la mutualité
française et l'association w e cf
on commence l'atelier en faisant un tour
des polluants de l'habitat pour que les
personnes puissent prendre conscience
que chacun au sein de son propre habitat
à ses propres paulon et ensuite on
travaille concrètement avec des produits
sur table on prend ces produits on
regarde les étiquettes ont regardé
pictogrammes de danger on regarde les
labels on regarde les compositions des
produits pour nous apprendre à
identifier les pôles ont qui sont cachés
dans ses produits de consommation
courante
apprendre à les identifier pour mieux
les éviter et mieux protéger sa santé
l'occasion pour les femmes de ce
quartier de s'informer sur les produits
les moins nuisibles à la santé
les pratiques d'hygiène à modifier car
elles ont aussi découvert que la
pollution intérieure et la plupart du
temps invisible un tapis tout neuf il
n'est pas polluant si il est polluant
parce qu'il est neuf il ya des denrées à
l'intérieur et qui font que des fibres
qui sont polluantes
donc bien sûr on veut pas tout supprimer
mais savoir au moins que quand on
déballe par exemple un nouveau
il y a de la pollution il ya les vernis
ya tout ça qu'ils sont dans le meuble en
question si on peut le mettre un peu sur
balcon avant de mettre dans la maison
c'est mieux mobilier produits du
quotidien et bricolage présente des
risques où se révèle dangereux pour la
santé et les bébés sont les plus
vulnérables face aux effets des
polluants chimiques et pour finir voici
l'agenda
tout d'abord à magny les hameaux rendez
vous le 16 décembre âgées handicap pour
participer à un groupe de parole sur le
thème des aidants familiaux
comment apporter son soutien à une
personne en situation de handicap
ces ateliers vous aide à trouver les
réponses et puis téléthon toujours à
trappes direction le gymnase broustal le
11 décembre pour participer à une série
d'événements sportifs dont les bénéfices
seront reversés au téléthon 2015
voilà check up c'est maintenant terminé
quant à moi je vous donne rendez-vous
dans deux semaines pour un prochain
numéro
et d'ici là prenez soin de vous